it started as a Turkish military
operation it ended with governments in
two capitals making urgent phone calls
the Turkish military was conducting air
strikes in Haka in Syria targeting
Kurdish fighters of the ypg group The
Operation was ordered after the Turkish
interior Ministry was targeted by a
suicide bomber on Sunday but American
troops took emergency cover as an armed
Turkish Stone came within 1 kilometer of
their positions when calls between the
capitals failed to Halt the oper
and the Drone moved to just 500 M away a
US jet shot it down the first time a
NATO member has attacked one of its
allies us commanders assessed that the
UAV which was now less than a half a
kilometer from US forces to be a
Potential Threat and US F6 Fighters
subsequently shot down the UAV in
self-defense at approximately 11:40
local time it's important to point out
that no US forces were injured during
the incident we have no indication that
uh that they uh that turkey was
intentionally targeting US forces us
defense secretary Lloyd Austin and his
new military Chief General CQ Brown
called their counterparts in anchora it
reported the emphasized Tura as an ally
but also the need to avoid similar
incidents the US considers the ypg as a
vital Ally in the fight against isil in
Syria but turquia has branded ypg as a
terrorist organization and a threat to
the state the US still continues to walk
with the ypg that is very hostile and
the direct threat to Turkey so in the
statement the US underlined that they
respect and understand turkey's security
concerns and still continue to work with
the
RPG us has about 900 troops in Syria
protecting oil fields and fighting isil
there have been recent tensions between
Washington and ankora not least Turkish
opposition to Sweden joining NATO which
was finally resolved turke officials say
carried out Thursday's operation as part
of its right to self-defense and has
warned other countries to stay away from
areas controlled by groups it will
continue to Target Alan Fischer aler
Washington make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer